une première cette année en
ile-de-france pour éviter la cohue
habituel de la rentrée universitaire les
trois académies de la région miser sur
la télématique depuis trois mois elle
pratique ces académies la procédure de
préinscription taper 36,14 code ravel
ravel comme recensement automatisée des
voeux des élèves alors foncez de mai
c'est le dernier carat vous aviez
vraiment des files d'attentes pour
entrer à l'université
un spectacle devenu classique depuis
longtemps à paris les universités de la
capitale attire toujours plus de monde
et pour s'inscrire les candidats se
bousculent est littéralement au
portillon
désormais et depuis cette année s'il ya
encombrement ce sera sur les lignes
minitel pour les inscriptions 90 les
trois académies d'île de france ont
choisi la télématique 36,14 code ravel
est désormais le mot de passe obliger
les 102 mille candidats au bac 90 passe
par le minitel pour indiqué l'université
et la filière de leur choix
les universités contacterons les
candidats après les résultats du bac en
fonction des voeux recensés par le
serveur ravel il y à fort à parier
qu'une fois de plus les facs parisiennes
seront très demandé et que tous les
souhaits ne pourront être exaucé
théoriquement la sélection se fera en
fonction de la proximité du domicile et
du temps de déplacement hier à vail
avait enregistré 80 mille connexions et
les préinscriptions télématique seront
closes demain soir mais si le système
rave elle évite la cohue
il ne résout en rien le manque de places
chronique dans les universités est le
problème
[Musique]